now to a troubling story from georgia
about the death and police custody of
briana greer a 20 year 28 year old
mother of two she fell out of a moving
patrol car while handcuffed now the
results of a state investigation
contradict what her family was told mark
straussman spoke with greer's parents we
should warn you there is body cam
footage and it is disturbing
brianna grier's parents called 9-1-1
because their daughter was in trouble
back on july 15 the 28 year old mother a
diagnosed schizophrenic had threatened
to hurt herself and her twin girls
you were looking for help i feel yes yes
i feel like it's my fault cause i called
him
and i'm trusting them
to take care of her not to harm her
two responding deputies struggled to
push greer into the back of a patrol car
less than a minute into the drive
disaster
we don't need ambulances
she somehow fell out of the rear
passenger door of the car and landed
face down by the side of the road
breathing but unconscious
the hancock county sheriff later told
greer's family she fell out after
kicking open the door
but a review by the georgia bureau of
investigation concluded that greer was
placed in the back seat with no seat
belt and the rear passenger side door of
the patrol car was never closed brianna
brianna this video never shows the
moment greer fell out of the car
she died six days later the hancock
county sheriff's office had no comment
unlike the greer family's lawyer just
reckless conduct on behalf of these
officers deliberate delivered
indifference
at the hands of somebody who was having
a mental health crisis her family's new
crisis
their grief we need answers we need
closure we need to know the truth
as part of their look into how greer
died state investigators here say they
looked at multiple videos greer's
parents have only seen the one you just
did they want to look at all of them
nate
mark thank you
so sad because the negligence
yeah the discrepancy between what the
hancock county sheriff told the family
which is that she kicked the door open
but the investigation found that she
wasn't strapped into her seat i just
really feel for the parents because
they're the ones that called police
hoping that they would help instead of
make the situation worse